alarming new research may tell us why
houston is seeing such a high spike
in coronavirus cases with houston's
texas medical center reportedly at 105
percent capacity
researchers at baylor college of
medicine say a strain of the virus in
that area has mutated and has become
even more contagious
than what we have seen so far joining me
now
dr cedric dark emergency medicine
physician and assistant professor at
houston's baylor college of medicine
he is also the founder of policy
prescriptions and a board member
of doctors for america doctor thank you
so much for being here with us today
we have been following a number of
states that have seen the spike in cases
along the sun belt if you could just
give us some insight to start the
conversation about what you're seeing
there in texas and more specifically in
houston
well yesterday was texas's deadliest day
of this pandemic over 100 people
died and i've seen reports that
refrigerated trucks are coming to texas
to be able to handle bodies because
there are not enough spaces in the
morgues
this is something that i experienced one
other time back when i was in medical
school
2001 during 9 11 i actually went to
medical school in new york
and from my 14th floor i could see down
onto the office of the chief medical
examiner and i could see
rows of refrigerated trucks a white tarp
that carried the bodies of the people
that were killed in the collapse of the
twin towers
but just to put it in perspective more
people have died in texas from covid
than those who died during the 9 11
attacks
and it's something uh particularly scary
because we're hardly close to the end of
this at all
and now we're seeing this new research
so this is the los alamos national
laboratory
they've discovered a mutation of the
virus that facilitates its spread
uh joseph petracino who's the chair of
molecular
virology and microbiology at baylor
college of medicine
he said that the one we have in the u.s
spreads better than the original
that originally emerged in china so what
does this mean
for houston for the houston area
potentially for the country
well it just means it's so much easier
for the disease to spread and for more
people to get infected and what that
really means is that people need to take
this
this seriously we need to really make
sure that everybody's masking up when
they're out in public
people need to socially distance from
people that aren't in their homes
because if we don't we're going to
lose control of the virus and you see
what's already happened in texas we
actually had a pretty good
grip on it earlier on in the pandemic in
april and going into may until
we reopened our economy at a breakneck
pace once we did that
cases started going up dramatically
increasing over the past two to three
weeks
almost at an exponential rate and so now
we're trying to get a handle on it again
to the point where the governor
had to reissue a mask order but in that
interim there was a period of about 67
days where the governor
prohibited people in houston from
issuing our own mass order
until he was forced to do it himself for
the entire state
your thoughts on the suggestion that
there should be
a nationwide mass mandate versus this
being done state by state
i mean i think that health care is best
delivered very very locally
and so you know what we should be doing
is trying to have
decisions made by local politicians
at all costs if we can i think it's a
mistake for someone to come in
and overrule what the local politicians
want to do
if that means they want to mask and you
know if it becomes necessary as it
became necessary in texas
for the sake of public health yes then
we need a mask order whether or not we
need one nationally i think at this
point it should be a state by state
decision
but if it gets to the point where it's
overwhelming the entire country then i
would call on the president
to make that order as well
houston among other cities in the in the
south in arizona some in florida have
been described as hot spots
how do you climb out of that what is the
strategy what do the people need to do
what do the providers need to do and
also the government the politicians that
are speaking and working to inform the
people
i think we need consistent leadership
all the way from the top down and as i
said before and i'll reiterate now
masking social distancing and taking
this
coronavirus seriously is what we
definitely need to do one of the other
things that we have to realize
is that our treatments in the medical
field are fairly limited right we have
oxygen that we can give to patients we
have antiviral rims
deserve that we can give to people to
shorten their hospital stays
dexamethasone is showing to be a
promising treatment for people that have
damage to their lungs but when it comes
to the simple intervention
something as easy as oxygen you have to
think about how much does that cost for
someone to actually
take care of that at home you know i was
looking up how much is an oxygen
concentrator it's somewhere on the order
of hundreds to maybe a thousand two
thousand three thousand dollars for that
machine
what do you do in texas where you have
18 percent of our population uninsured
how are we going to make sure that
people that need such a simple therapy
actually have
access to it and so what i would say
right now is we have a moral
imperative to one another to address
things like the social determinants of
health things like uninsurance
so that people that are infected people
that are sick
can get the care that they need so they
can recover and return to being
functional members of society
absolutely dr cedric dark a very
important point made there at the end of
the conversation
appreciate your insight thanks for
joining us